how do you teach a kid to talk humans
teach speech with zillions of
reinforcement Cycles baby doesn't do
anything then baby makes a noise hey
look they're making noise celebrate
celebrate celebrate baby makes more
noise more noise eventually one of those
noises approximates a word we freak out
so then it makes more and more and more
sounds like that because it gets
positive reinforcement and then all of a
sudden it makes a full word everyone
freaks out and then it starts making
more noise and more words and then what
do we do we tell it to shut up because
it talks so much it's just these
reinforcement Cycles that's how we humor